after 17 years on YouTube I look back
and I regret any time that I've made
shortsighted decisions instead of
decisions based on Legacy impact and the
ultimate brand that I want to build this
includes pushing products you don't
actually believe in or jumping on trends
that don't actually align with your
channel topic this is a huge Temptation
that new creators fall into because
you're so hungry to do this full-time
you're so flattered perhaps by getting
an invitation to your first brand deal
or sponsorship and all of those things
are good making money getting views
building your personal brand but if
you're compromising what you actually
believe about a product or you're
chasing views and vanity metrics
disconnected from the core purpose of
your channel then ultimately you're
going to be sacrificing your long-term
brand just for shortterm views and money